the most effective martial art for
winning street fight he talked about
rule sets and streets
I think you've talked about being have
you ever been in a street fight yeah
just one yeah nothing special nothing
crazy hey yeah you don't talk about that
time like for self-defense purposes
will be a strategy on the street whoever
wins the street fights whoever's willing
to take it the furthest the fastest you
know what I mean if you're thinking
you're gonna box and he's biting you
poking your eyes that guy's gonna win he
wants him more you know what I mean
that's why the crackheads fight they go
for the kill straight away you know so I
feel like it's more about who's willing
to do the most that's going to win that
fight
fastest the most fastest
who's got the least to lose you know
okay we could also Define winning
differently because you could also run
away
but in terms of technique wise
wrestling I think if it's a one-on-one
I'd go I'd go wrestle wrestler wins but
if it's like a you know it's like a
multiple people you gotta go Muay Thai
stay on their feet can't go down to the
ground if it's more than one person
yeah big double leg Maybe
yeah double A put him asleep on the on
the impact right forehead to the ground
yeah what's the goal here is to win the
fight not go to prison
um I haven't thought of it through that
way yeah certainly yeah yeah not going
not to not to kill mutual combat here in
Texas we're good
is that in Texas do you know with the
paperwork for that looks like you have
to actually sign something can you just
say oh I don't need to find out
I did hear a story where guys were on
Sixth Street and they looked at a cop
they were like mutual combat mutual
combat yeah and just got like the cops
to say yes and just duked it out it
could be false though
that sounds crazy I'm saying
I I kind of admire that but I've also
been playing Red Dead Redemption
recently so I've like internalized the
cowboy a little a little too much